all right welcome to other hang out we
are with rich the inspire photographer
episode 7 rich it's been a while what is
happening what were you asking what is
that what is this yeah what is on let's
go on you he's a legendary Chinese God /
warrior I fine yeah this is morganite
but but we don't need to get into a nap
up to you though oh so what's happening
tell me ah you know all kinds is
happening on on my work front good stuff
which is key been keeping me busy but
not much has been happening in terms of
my channel and videos actually you're
frozen right now are you still there I'm
here I'm here is I'm just I'm enthralled
here i'm taking my heart I guess is the
reception in mind you're like frozen go
on but so not much has been going on in
mind and I've been really kind of
bumping up against that weather actually
even just throw in the towel all this
stuff Wow because I hate not keeping my
work you know and I keep saying I'm
going to do stuff that ice my actions
obviously speak and I'm not doing it so
it's like it's like pulling teeth so
it's like what's the point just give it
up you're obviously not ready for this
just let it go ah well do you want to do
it what feels right how come you're not
doing it you know it's so strange except
it's a mixed up thing it's like it's a
toll roller coaster on the high year
excited you pump your pumping out a
bunch of stuff and then all sudden you
crash and then he's like you can't even
see their the light and it's like it's
just a roller coaster it's like you have
any uh any tips for them I mean what is
that all mean you're just driving me
nuts well yeah yeah is it something that
do you not want to continue because it
feels right like it feels right not to
continue or because you're afraid of
what you have to do well you know at
this point right now
no fuzzy for me but the clearest thing
for me now is that is that unbeliever
actions and if I say one thing but I do
another that I'm gonna believe what I do
and so what I do or lack of doing is
kind of telling me where I'm at or what
I'm going so it's like who which rich am
I gonna believe this rich or that rich
the rich its feet sir the rich but it
does or doesn't do yeah and I mean
obviously you're not following through
on what you said you're going to do but
so it's there it's the reason behind it
you know is it is it is it that you're
not interested in it that you don't see
value that it's not something you want
to do or is it that you're afraid of it
right because it's either is it's a
logical reason or it's a logical reason
right if you're if it's based out of
fear then that's not good it was based
out of this doesn't feel right right now
that's a different story yeah so what is
it yes the hard question Eddie if I know
the answer that I probably have the
answer to that so you know what I you
know logically speaking I would say that
just I'm not sure if I'm if it's lipids
to work his way then I'll be worthwhile
can you run a little bit I don't have
the time to put into the pan of time I
need to put into it and when I do start
to do this stuff it's like it's not
consistent so my afraid of it I think I
kind of lost some of that fear going on
camera like I still don't produce videos
with me on camera but I'm just really
seeing the point in it right now it's
like my afraid if I don't know when you
care anymore like even here come on I
don't know who's watching if anyone's
watching it all or if anyone watching
people are watching you Here I am
talking about how I'm like you know all
the stuff i'm saying so it's like I
don't know if it's if that's even the
case anymore of me being afraid of it
cool well that's good man even that in
itself is some that's a massive growth
compared to the rich that was right the
third of the black one it was like okay
that was the obstacle
fear of being on camera so now I don't
have that excuse anymore yeah kind of a
different level I don't worry I'm not
really afraid I don't you care about it
so what's next what's up you gone you've
gone like beyond full circle it's
awesome i love it the transformation is
real um so so where do you want to spend
your time I think that's the bigger
thing you think of where you are
spending your time where do you want to
spend your time where do I wanna spend
my fun you know ultimately if I can have
to work work wasn't a thing and I'll
just probably just create these video
project crave these projects on a
consistent basis do it on my own kind of
fun case that still I not not even sure
it would be consistent but I would think
it would be for don't think I would be
doing right because I that's that's kind
of the fun thing to me to create these
videos but a lot of times I get into a
frog face because then I'm like okay so
these kind of videos are inspired videos
are you going to do some videos about
photo tips are you going to do videos
about no video tips that are going to
configure those about behind the scenes
of you working and we may all seem to be
like so such they're all seem to be
their own thing that I don't know I'm
not really which one am I going to do am
I going to do all of them at times it
makes sense to do all of them and at
other times it's like it's a complete
like but nothing makes sense you're
you're a you're a tough case mr. rich I
no no I yeah how many times I already
say this I'd love to see myself in front
of myself so I could give that guy a
good beating but wake up so I mean the
idea behind it is that it's your it's
your gift to the world right it's your
it's your mark it's the thing that you
want to leave and improve people's lives
uh and if you if that's not of interest
like you don't want to have an impact on
a bigger scale and you just want to do
your work it's not not as anything
that's really wrong with that just maybe
sounds like that's not the path
like you don't want to have a big impact
yeah is that that is it true no that's
not true i do I have it involved you
want to have an impact but you're not
doing the things exactly neither did
have an impact so how badly do you want
it yeah that's what I'm saying it's like
okay so which saying XYZ when you're
doing something completely different so
who are we gonna believe so why are you
doing something different you want to do
it you commit to do it you just you know
scheduled time to do it but you don't do
it yeah what what comes up like why is
it a mental thing is it like you feel
it's not important is it a something
gets in the way you a project comes up
but you wake up one day and it like it's
gone and yeah i would say probably
combination but the most prevalent thing
just be like the mental state and when
you get to it it's like it's not there
it's like I basically that waiting for
it to be there rather than
self-generating I would assume that if
you it's jet first chip self-generating
and then it's right it's there is that
right or is it always there for you know
um I think the thing that really helped
me and what I'm kind of leaning towards
is I'm I kind of think your environment
sucks right now yeah like your your your
physical environment your your you know
whatever you're consuming is just like
holding you back from doing something
great um and I could be off base but
that's just kind of the vibe I'm getting
from Annie that you buying a physical
model for example here's what here's
what happens to a lot of entrepreneurs I
may be YouTube you listen to it you look
maybe after this in your this this
session or you listen to an interview on
a TED talk or tony robbins tape or
something like you you talked to one guy
and that inspires you right and then
you're off and you're like oh I gotta go
home I gotta do this like I'm all pumped
up and fired
oh yeah here we go and then the next
thing you wake up and it's all gone well
and then you like back to what you're
doing before and like oh it's just in my
what am i doing I don't know what to do
and then you fall back into your habits
yeah it's that does that sound like it's
on or am I not allowed phone records for
a bang on yeah so this is super common
and it mean common for me to uh in that
you have a environment and a lifestyle
that holds you where you are right your
look in your office like this has this
has meaning right is the reason why this
guy is here the wall has meaning you
know my morning routine has meeting and
it's all designed to try to get me into
the state of thinking bigger and doing
more challenge myself to try to do
something bigger than what i'm doing now
because i would get like that too you
know i could be lazy in the morning and
whatever and then I meet an entrepreneur
and I'm on fire right like I'm giving
them ideas and ready to go when I come
back that was great what I awesome eat
and I'm like I'm killing on my computer
and whatever making calls whatever I
need to do pumping it all in and then I
wake up the next day it's like start
from scratch war so that is the
indicator that my morning routine sucks
that my environment sucks because it
allows me to be lazy I'm just being
reactionary where when something happens
to happen if i have a meeting or watch a
video or read a book at four in the
afternoon whenever it happens that's
when i get inspired where if you want to
start the day off ready to go then you
need to create a morning routine and an
environment that puts you into that
state that make sense am I talking over
to you here let that's pretty good
sense so what I'll take yeah what's the
how-to so I can explain how i do it and
maybe there's lessons for you okay the
first thing I do in the morning is my
wife leaves work like she's out she
works early and she's out the door be
five and wake up so the first thing I'll
do is I'll just send her a facebook
message like a happy face or something
just like starting today would love
something quick so she knows I'm up uh
then I have a little notepad next to me
and i will just write down three things
i'm grateful for that day whatever comes
sometimes it's super a logical i got my
loving wife my awesome son you know and
then sometimes it's like I'm grateful
for the Sun you know I'm grateful for
air I don't know whatever I'm feeling
that morning I just write it down um and
that may be super cheesy I may not work
for everybody but I find that for me
starting the day with a little bit of
like super tiny little bit of reflection
and love and gratitude just kind of
opens me up like I'm ready to go it's
not like I'm Rocco but it suggests it's
like nourishing to my soul that's all um
I feel like I'm a happier person and
grateful for being a lot kind of thing
the next thing I do is I go to my
computer and I put on music and I have a
belief playlist I don't talk about it
before but I'm a believe playlist and I
put that on because music instantly
changes your state put on songs that
make you I think we've talked about this
right you put on solids and make you
dance right I have you can look at my
list but I'm sure we have you know
different tastes there's no one song
that you gotta listen to this song it's
going to get you in the zone but having
those different having that playlist
I've got about a hundred songs on there
and I just put it on randomly that that
gets me you know I'm sitting there with
my smoothie usually have a smoothie
right here right and I'm like
hmm you know Bob in just naturally
things that you do you like those are
the songs you want the things that get
you high energy ready to go um then I
turn to the big wine a little why and
the big wise like why am I doing this
why is it so important than constantly
reminded myself with my goal to help a
billion entrepreneurs and the little
wise are the the comments that I get on
my youtube channel I look at those like
those inspiring getting feedback from
from from people on my youtube channel
saying hey that was a great video that
makes me like oh the stuff I'm doing has
impact right because sometimes the big
goal can be too big sometimes and it
feels like oh I'm never going to hit
that how am I going to do that but then
you see like the little wise little
interactions that makes you want to keep
going and recently I found the biggest
struggle for me was uh thinking bigger
where I found in a lot of my circles I'm
the I'm the biggest thinker in a lot of
my circles and that's not like to brag
and I feel like I feel like that's a
negative like I don't want to be the big
I want somebody out there doing
something way more ambitious than I am
and because I'm the most ambitious in
most of my groups I found that you
settle like what I'm doing is great
everybody says what I'm doing is great
that's awesome so I just keep doing what
I'm doing but I'm not like pushing
boundaries anymore and sort of created
the I don't know if you saw my channel
the ents Breslau series but it's a
morning clip that comes out every
morning at 7am and it's from a famous
entrepreneur and it's a message that
they have for success something that
kind of makes you think a little bit
bigger it could be Sylvester Stallone or
Howard Schultz or Bill Gates or whoever
and it's a short clip like four minutes
five minutes usually and and I start my
day with that like I made it selfishly
for me because I needed it because I
needed the shot every morning too
me going and luckily other people have
followed in and watched it and they they
now need the shot every morning to they
start their day we all start our day
together watching the ants wrestle
series and that sets me up you know that
that all of that combined sets me up for
being in the zone and starting my day
and trying to do something better than I
did yesterday and so it's finding
whatever whatever works for you if I
would try to think about all of the
people and all of the resources and if
its books or articles or videos or
speeches or whatever like things that in
the past have inspired you to go home
and start going crazy schedule that in
as part of your morning routine instead
of accidentally stumbling across at one
day and being inspired at six at nine
and and then going to sleep later and
not doing anything and it doesn't work
one hundred percent right like I'm not
gonna say every single day I wake up a
bra right does that look like again just
like we should do like slow motion so
that then tunde is right in to say true
music gets you in the zone so it's your
music on um whatever whatever that looks
like for you uh I would try to figure
that out and make it part of your daily
routine because if you want to if you
didn't want to do something bigger like
it wasn't interesting for you cool like
move on to something else but you said
you want to you said if you had the time
you would do it but it's getting in the
way and I feel like it's your
environment that sucks right now so
redesign your schedule redesign your
space like I can't see much of what's
happening in your I don't that's your
office or whatever but like when you
look around your office is it is there
meaningful stuff there that inspires you
and it's totally personal like for me
this Guan Yu statue has a big story uh
you know the airplane has a story for
you maybe it's maybe it's your wife and
kids and like you're doing it for them
and that like big picture in the wall of
you and then maybe that's kind of what
get you going or it's a picture of Steve
job whatever like no judgment but
something that your environment
everything you look at and everything
that you do is part of your schedule to
start the day sets you up to be
energized and successful I like that
idea city good so what can you do what's
an ideal day look like to start with to
get you excited whatever my takeaways
that one cast me what like what can you
what sort of just intellectually yeah I
get that like action sets what can you
do tell you know what I'm getting from
that is that I can clip and put pictures
on my wall you know stuff that has
meaning to me that inspires me come and
give me that bigger picture what I'm
doing and why I'm doing it creating that
face which i think i created and while
back and i completely forgot about it so
having that playlist that i play of you
know short inspirational speeches and
really get me going i really like
putting some music is really great
because I notice that music really helps
if you're in a whatever kind of mood for
the track on and immediately it's
different so it's a matter of getting
into the habit of doing because my habit
is the opposite so getting to the habit
of doing it is where i'm at right now so
putting things in place that will begin
this habit so it's not like really
breaking an old habit by instilling this
new habit so it's getting to that zone
so this stuff we kept putting pictures
up on the wall giving a music thing it's
a motivational inspirational comments
feature that i like what else can i do
here what else is there anything other
than that then when you think is useful
you're going to get in that I like that
gratitude getting to that
and a grateful kind of place writing
some of that what may help you uh is
make a list of all the things that you
want to do and then look at that list
and then start your day going through
them so if it's if you like the
gratitude thing for me it's honestly
like two minutes it's not a not a 20
minute meditation on but maybe that's
you like do you write for me it's a
two-lap thing but you know make a list
of the five things that you want to do
in the morning they kind of get you
ready and excited so you don't forget so
if it's gratis in the morning great for
me I just have that I have my iPad and I
have my little stack of paper next in my
bed and I'm when I wake up that's what i
see so I grab the ipad i messaged my
wife and then i get the notepad and and
i write down three things and that kind
of sets me up to start but you could
have the list the thing that's that is
then still missing I feel is the
connection to what you're trying to do
the connection that the work you're
doing is meaningful and has value and
makes the world a better place somehow
so it's the big y of like what are you
trying to do with inspire to inspire the
world's inspire people you know what's
your message and then the little wise or
the like I don't know how many comments
you get on your stuff on your YouTube
videos if that's if you get at least one
a day to help you or not for me before I
got comments I just made a powerpoint
file with with some of my favorite
comments because I didn't get enough
right because i got like what a month so
it take them and and just put them all
together in one powerpoint and i would
look at that in the morning quickly like
just glance head and say well you know
just a reminder like the work that I'm
doing really is important to people well
I know you've gotten some good comments
on your videos it may not be consistent
because you're not consistent but but I
know you've gotten some great ones that
that if I look that would inspire me to
want to keep going for the for the
playlist I'd also encourage mixing it up
because if you hear the same speech
every morning it's going to
is going to lose his impact so that's
why I have a hundred songs speeches
together and I just do it random so I
may not hear the same thing for you know
the next week or something so it that
variety i find helps yeah it's a little
bit idea if I had to just pick one I
would do the music because it changes
you instantly your put it on with
purpose right like you put it on because
you want to do something important and
just getting excited and moving right
gets you ready to do work well yeah I
think I think that will help you with
with your mindset you know you may you
may want to look at to the people in
your life but that's like the next step
but you know who are your friends what
are they telling you you know do they do
they hold you where you are do they help
push you to be the best rich possible
yeah do you have the right people in
your network right now for where you
want to be or do they just keep you at
rich you know not not doing what he
shouldn't be lazy alright most people
that's like your product of your
environment most people are like that so
you're likely to be as successful as
your parents are you like to visit us
what your friends are right it's like
and it's really hard to shake that
environment where i want to be great and
to be great i had to be surrounded by
greatness and great things in great
uncle and I don't have you know a Howard
Schultz that I can talk to and see his
huge vision or Steve Jobs and his huge
vision I want to be like that and so I
don't know those people but I surround
myself with their aura their quotes
their speeches their thoughts and that
inspires me to be I don't want to be
steve jobs i want to be me but looking
up to those people helps me be the best
version of me helps
me to do more to do better and that's a
super common like everybody has this
issue almost not many people are
fortunate enough to have an environment
that just accidentally happens to push
them to be amazing right you got to got
to design your life and it's worth the
time some questions coming in James
where can I find the entrepreneurial
message again I think it's talk about
the answer s oh that's every morning on
my channel just look for in stress or
just every morning on the channel the
new video will come out and you'll see
it somebody suggest Jane Anna you can
use a phil d moment that I don't know
that is fil di moment so and if you're
still watching nemo let's know where
home is another thought if the problems
the environment change it i'm usually
not in the office i usually work at a
starbucks be surrounded by people so I
mean that could be a great point too I
don't need people around me to be
productive I'm very introverted yeah I'm
not really other way to I needed to be a
need to be living on my own and a part
of my issue is that i worked at home
yeah yeah whole family's home yeah like
my boys are home schooled so there's
always acting and stuff there's leaving
right now someone's right out that side
that door knocking enough you can hear
not always there and yes I keep kind of
cycling going out coming back working
out of my home office and always coming
back to home lobsters comfortable right
I better bidding yeah yeah I mean and I
know your wife and you have a wife who
loves you the tears and and supports you
like nobody else I and I think she'd be
on board with you if you said I need
this to be not just successful in
business but to be like a happy or
person because you bring when you are
excited and energetic and feel like
you're creating great things in your
business you bring that to your family
to like a better husband you're better
add add to your kids when you have
energy and you're on on top of the world
that has ripple effects through your
whole life yeah that means you need to
be in a room that's totally empty and
soundproof and like nobody bothers you
for these hours or something that could
help your business and your life and
your marriage and your your father hood
right so you got to figure out what what
you need to be back even to be happy
that could be a great big move for me to
actually have a dedicated office space
outside of my slaves here so that I put
myself in that environment ok this is
work focused on and there's no way
nowhere to go out to no one to kind of
pull my attention because I'm here to
just be dedicated work so I and I did
that for a while ago ought to feel like
the library here where there's rooms you
can book yeah I think I just kind of got
to go back there and do that it's funny
how I go through these circles where
I'll be doing it I'll do all the right
things and I'll forget it gradually
forget about all the right things and go
right back down to doing all the old
things so here's what happens and this
is really curious I find it really
curious we have these habits that we
want to develop for ourselves right
these habits that we know we should do
that we feel help us uh when you miss
one habit you're probably going to fall
off with everything else so for example
if you want to wake up early when a
meditate you want to show gratitude you
want to stick to a healthy diet you want
to work out if that's like your morning
routine if you wake up late you missed
the first thing you're probably not
going to work out you're probably gonna
cheat on your diet you're probably gonna
just right off the whole day and say
I'll pick it up again tomorrow that's
often what happens what happens to me it
happens to a lot of people uh and what
can help reverse that is being
consistent with a simple habit every
morning that's part of why i created an
espresso because I want people to get in
a habit of coming
every day watching the video and getting
inspired and if you can keep that habit
which is pretty simple it's you know
three to five minutes in the morning
it's a you know energy shot for you then
you're much more likely to keep all the
other habits that you've set for
yourself so if you started going to the
library and that was really helpful
there was probably something you're
doing before before you go to the
library that you stop doing and then
because you stop doing that and stop
going to the library then you forgot
about it you moved on and now you're in
a rut so whatever that first thing is
you do in the morning make it really
powerful and make it easy to do cuz
going to library takes time right you
gotta get to the car you gotta drive or
you're walking like you got to get ready
you gotta pack a lunch you gotta get
your gear there's a lot of time that
happens and it's easy to say I'm just
not going to do that today and if you do
that enough days in a row you just
forget about it and you move on to
something else and forgot that I was
even a habit you wanted to keep more so
start with something that is again
powerful and easy to keep to and that
sets up a chain reaction for you for the
rest of the day to keep your all your
other habits because that first one you
miss it you're it's really hard to get
back you can do it but it's really hard
to get back on that train if you miss
the first slot well um more comments
thumbs up for the wall of inspiration oh
the the filthy moment anaerobic is [ __ ]
it let's do it there you go James Lee
right now I'm in the same boat people
saying don't be discouraged by the
cycles is a common thing um I think that
could really help you ya know it can and
it will and it has in just a matter of
keeping it consistent consistency seems
to be the devil I'm dancing with for a
while now haven't mastered it yet but
because once i get it consistent will be
so much easier to do stuff because you
know you're in the right state
and the consistency build up I get it
intellectually just I haven't
incorporated it on a deeper level yet so
what's the first thing you can do every
morning something simple powerful easy
that you can keep to every day well I
think the easiest thing that comes to
mind that's simple and easy just to put
on the playlist just press play and he's
surprised but what phase you know you
like he said you set up a hundred songs
and low motivational speeches together
put on random highly likely you're gonna
get surprised every day with what starts
and it's all already good because you
already predetermined what you're going
to put on there so that it could be the
simplest thing to do I kind of start and
me I'm fine for me not if your day I
wake up in a great mood so if I put that
on and it gets you in a good mood and it
sets everything up like plot man I don't
wake up every day in a good mood no we
we have it like you guys that are doing
your thing and our successful have it
like always perfect but I get that it's
not you guys ever want the same one
swing the same just the habits that they
have in place it makes them different so
you already have your playlist you have
to build it I have a playlist okay but
it's probably short it's only like
twenty twenty something in more videos
so I'm gonna scoured today my action is
I'm gonna scour the internet for some
great stuff and your your YouTube
channel and add a bunch of stuff to a
playlist just start it up but doesn't
have to be perfect just to start it off
and I'll revise it as I go on yeah I
love it and and then I would have a
visual cue ideally two things see if
you're open to it 11 just some kind of
print out a piece of paper somewhere on
your desk that says will turn on the
videos I'm serious more wall is sticking
out somewhere just something that's
always like when you come to sit down
your desk or stand up in my case more
there's a note there that you're gonna
do it just make it easy to do it and you
you turn that on immediately you
other thing that really helps that i'm a
big believer in is this adult break the
chain theory where this came from jerry
seinfeld which you don't associate with
motivation but anyway having a calendar
where you just put an X every day that
you do it a visual countless something
you print out or you go by this dollar
store whatever not on the computer like
something you can hold in your hand and
every time you do that have it you can
put an X on that day it sounds really
simple and stupid I think I don't have
to do that but seeing that X and join it
makes you want to do it again the next
day makes you want to keep that chain
going so that you don't break it so like
entry level level one is just do a sign
somewhere handwritten like do that today
make the playlist i love it on top of it
commit to writing down on a piece of
paper watch the flail is so you have
that visual cue in front of you and if
you want to take it up a level have that
calendar where you can x every day again
super simple you can print it up tonight
i probably would recommend doing that
because when you're in the zone and if
you're working on it you're much more
likely to do it then say i'll do it
tomorrow if i'm not going to do it so
don't break the chain and i think just
setting that up as a as a habit and
routine if you can keep that for one
month until our next session i think
that will already have a big impact on
your productivity in your life great
weight and I booked our next session
already I like it thinking ahead um oh
well we're a little bit over I've gotta
run to another call thank you for
there's more comments thank you voting
for watching you could check out rich um
what's the best way your YouTube channel
I guess you've got a lot of my you can
count on them yeah oh and work on
posting stuff on it now go check them
out thanks rich practice sandy thanks
Evan thanks guys bye